depuis la fenêtre de leur hôtel on
n'imagine pas ce qu'il se passe en ville
à khartoum à le chaos règne suite au
coup d'état les militaires retiennent
plusieurs ministres et dirigeants du
pays les habitants descendus par
milliers dans les rues réclame leur
restitution
les lignes aériennes sont coupés joueuse
et entraîneur de l'équipe de football
algérienne sont bloqués sur place
et puis c'est pas évident ce pose des
questions fait preuve de solidarité sas
en a pas on n'a pas le choix on est
quand même en sécurité l'hôtel et est
gardé par un par les militaires et on a
un peu à l'écart de la ville il avoue
que c'est pas non plus facile au
quotidien on soit les des messages aussi
de nos proches qui s'inquiètent parce
qu'ils voient les images à la télé ça
qu'est ce qu'on peut voir ça peut faire
peur mais en tout cas on essaye tout
relativiser l us orléans on s'inquiète
pour ses joueuses franco algérienne
hélas les négos ça se passe entre l'état
algérien l état se donnaient d'abord
confié à la fifa la situation relève
désormais d etat algérien et soudanais
le club demeure impuissant
tenez le coup jusqu'à le plus tôt
possible j'espère que l'avion va
militaire va pouvoir repartir d'alger le
plus rapidement possible notre champ
d'action est relativement restreint
sinon prendre contact avec la fédération
algérienne pour pour se tenir au courant
des évolutions des situations leurs
coéquipières prennent régulièrement des
nouvelles
dans le cadre du football être faire se
retrouver pour elle dans des situations
comme ça un peu de guerre c'est vrai que
c'est un peu difficile à réaliser on est
inquiète mais elle arriva quand même
nous rassurer du mais qu'elles peuvent
d'où elles sont pour l'heure l'équipe
d'algérie est en contact avec son
ambassade au soudan d'après les
dernières informations elle devrait
rentrer chez elle d'ici samedi